und jetzt schauen wir noch mal ein
bisschen tiefer rein wie viel Patienten
liegen da äh aktuell auf den
Intensivstation und wir schauen hier auf
die Karte der Hospitalisierung noch
einmal also
4.2003 corona-patienten sind aktuell in
den Krankenhäusern erfasst dass die
aktuellen Zahlen vom
Robert-Koch-Institut und dann rufen wir
uns noch mal in Erinnerung was
eigentlich die Prognosen uns gesagt
haben vor Weihnachten da war zum
Beispiel das Institut der
Intensivmediziner dass die wie das hat
davor gewarnt dass rund um Weihnachten
wir
6000 Patienten auf den Stationen liegen
haben werden 6.000 corona-patienten das
Robert-Koch-Institut hat gesagt dass es
etwa 5.700 sein werden also das waren
damals die schockprognosen am Anfang
Dezember für diese Zeit jetzt rund um
oder kurz nach Weihnachten ich schreibe
die Zahl noch mal auf
1000 das war also die alarmprognose vom
TV von den intensivärzten und ganz
ähnlich auch vom Robert-Koch-Institut
aktuell liegen wir zum Glück deutlich
drunter bei
4.2003 und gleichzeitig greifen eben
jetzt diese verschärften Maßnahmen die
auf Basis dieser Zahlen damals
beschlossen wurden brauchen wir die
heute noch darüber wollen wir jetzt
diskutieren hier im Studio mit Sandra
und mit unserem Bild Meinung Chef
Philipp piatov
ganz genau philipp ist bei uns herzlich
Willkommen Philipp was geht ihr durch
den Kopf wenn du das siehst was ist das
schon wieder schief gelaufen ja man muss
es man muss es so hart sagen die
schockprognosen des
Robert-Koch-Instituts die
schockprognosen der Intensivmediziner
waren wieder überhöht waren wieder
falsch und daran gibt es einige
erstaunliche Punkte ich glaube man kann
es keinem Experten keinem Institut keine
Behörde übel nehmen dass sie sich mit
Blick auf die nächste Welle mehrere
Monate im Voraus verschätzt verrechnet
viele Dinge kann man einfach nicht
berechnen und eigentlich müssten wir
auch froh sein dass es jetzt anders
gekommen ist aber trotzdem absolut mal
wieder mit den Ängsten der Leuten
gespielt da muss man aber auch glaube
ich diesmal wirklich einmal streng sein
und das nicht konsequenzenlos und uns
vorbeiziehen lassen denn man hat sich
hier vermodelliert verrechnet nicht in
Bezug auf die nächsten Monate sondern in
Bezug auf die wenigen nächsten Tage am 3
Dezember saß RKI-Präsident Lothar Wieler
in der Bundespressekonferenz und hat
gesagt aktuell liegen 4 800 Personen mit
Corona auf Intensivstationen und die
Belastung wird in den nächsten Wochen
steigen wenige Tage danach erreichte die
Zahl der Intensivpatienten mit 4.900
circa ihren Höhepunkt und Feld seitdem
und das lagern wir auf der Karte nochmal
uns anschauen wir haben die Grafik
gerade schon gesehen also zeig uns noch
mal ganz kurz was waren die
entscheidenden Zeitpunkte Anfang
Dezember eben das war der Zeitpunkt wo
die Prognosen veröffentlicht wurden auch
von rki-chef Lothar Wieler erster
Zwölfter genau am ersten 12 und am
zweiten 12 gab es die entscheidenden
Prognosen vom divi und vom RKI die haben
sich natürlich auch auf die Maßnahmen
ausgewirkt denn am 2 Dezember kam Bund
und Länder damals noch Unterführung von
Bundeskanzlerin Angela Merkel zusammen
und Maßnahmen zu verschärfen da wurde
bundesweit 2G beschlossen da wurde de
facto ein Lockdown für ungeimpft
beschlossen basierend auf den Prognosen
da hat Michael Müller noch gesagt ich
hoffe dass es uns mit diesen Maßnahmen
gelingt die Zuspitzung der Situation auf
bisschen Intensivstationen zu verhindern
und dann wenige Tage nachdem diese
Prognosen getätigt wurden begann schon
der Abschwung auf den Intensivstationen
und das lag nicht an den beschlossenen
Maßnahmen
da seht ihr doch dass die Maßnahmen
gegriffen haben da sagst du das kann gar
nicht sein der Zeitraum war nicht
möglich wenn Maßnahmen gewirkt haben
wenn Maßnahmen wirken dann immer erst
mit einer Verzögerung von mehreren
Wochen bis sie sich auf den
Intensivstationen bemerkbar machen ja
also stellt sich wiederum anders die
Frage brauchen wir die Maßnahme jetzt
überhaupt gar nicht mehr und kann man
die jetzt auch so kurzfristig wieder
abschaffen ja ich möchte jetzt nicht den
gleichen Fehler begehen wie das RKI und
das Stevie und meinen eigenen Prognosen
stellen und sagen ach wir kriegen das
auch alles ohne Maßnahmen mit aber wir
brauchen da mehr Transparenz und wir
brauchen auch vielleicht nicht nur diese
sogenannte Worst Case Kommunikation dass
man immer nur vom schlimmsten Fall
ausgeht dann es gibt ein massives
Glaubwürdigkeitsproblem gerade wir haben
Maßnahmen aufgrund von Prognosen dann
stellt er sich kurz darauf heraus die
Prognosen waren komplett falsch und
jetzt haben wir neue Maßnahmen
beschlossen verschärfen sie wieder
basierend auf weiteren Prognosen wie
soll ich denn als Bürger guten Gewissens
sagen tja gut bislang lagen sie zweimal
falsch aber dieses Mal wird es schon
stimmen so geht das nicht da muss die
Politik aufklären da muss das RKI
aufklären da muss die wie aufklären und
nicht so naja kann passieren
glücklicherweise ist es anders gekommen
sondern wir müssen den die Details gehen
und wissen wie konnte das passieren und
zwar immer und immer wieder und habt ihr
ja auch das Robert-Koch-Institut
angefragt auch die Intensivmediziner den
Verband der intensiv Ärzte sind die so
drauf dass die aktuell sagen ja gut also
es kann in der corona-krise halt viel
Veränderungen geben man liegt nicht
immer richtig in dem Moment lagen wir
definitiv falsch sind die so ehrlich
also das Robert-Koch-Institut hatte
gestern offenbar keine Zeit um unsere
Anfrage zu beantworten die
Intensivmediziner vom DB haben sich
geäußert Professor Dr Gernot Marx hat
gesagt ja es ist nicht so eingetreten
wie von ihm und von seinen Medizinern
prognostiziert er sagt allerdings das
lag daran dass sehr viel mehr Menschen
auf den Intensivstationen gestorben sind
als von den Modellierern prognostiziert
das heißt es wurden sehr viel mehr
Betten frei weil unerwartet viele
Menschen gestorben sind das ist erstmal
seine Behauptung der gehen wir nach da
wollen wir auch alle Daten wissen
wir müssen herausfinden was in diesem
Dezember passiert ist warum alle
Modellierer derart falsch schlagen
Philipp lassen uns noch mal ganz kurz
zum Abschluss über omicon sprechen alle
Welt spricht drüber wir warten auf diese
Welt auf diese Wand die angekündigt ist
aber auch hier passiert irgendwie nichts
genau also die umicron Welle wird
garantiert kommen wie in Deutschland
werden es nur als allerletzte merken
weil wir im datenblindflug sind das hat
RKI Präsident Lothar Wieler mit seinen
unerschütterlichen Selbstvertrauen vor
einigen Wochen bei der Pressekonferenz
angekündigt wir werden jetzt einfach
erstmal ganz lange nicht wissen was los
ist
auf den Intensivstationen ja aber die
Inzidenzen die
können wir uns wirklich in die Haare
schmieren die sind einfach unvollständig
die Frage ist aber nicht nur was
passiert mit Omikron denn ich würde da
Herrn Professor Drosten dem chefirologen
der Charité widersprechen und sagen nein
nicht Omicron schreibt die Regeln wer
das gesagt hat sondern das machen immer
noch wir das macht die Politik das
machen die Menschen die wir gewählt
haben und dass die Frage wie werden wir
damit umgehen werden wir wie die Briten
erstmal locker bleiben Boris Johnson hat
gestern gesagt es wird mit mir erstmal
keine regelverschärfung geben im
Gegenteil er verkürzt die Quarantäne
Dauer von 10 auf 7 Tagen werden wir das
auch machen oder werden wir schauen wie
Omi Content tatsächlich einschlägt was
Infektionen dann steht infizieren sich
Menschen und ihre Kontaktpersonen müssen
dann auch in Quarantäne und dann können
irgendwann tausende vielleicht
hunderttausende Polizisten Pfleger auch
Journalisten nicht mehr zu arbeiten